قبل ساعات من دخول الهدنه الخامسه حيز
التنفيذ في السودان بقيت العاصمه الخرطوم
بمدنها الثلاث عنوان المعارك التي تحولت
الى حرب شوارع في الخرطوم بحري قالت قوه
الدعم السريع ان الجيش قصف نقاطه مركزها
في ضاحيه كافوري ومحيط المنطقه الصناعيه
شرقيه المدينه غير بعيد من هناك كان محيط
القصر الجمهوري مسرح اشتباكات المتقطعه
بين الطرفين وشهدت اعمده دخان تتصاعد وسط
العاصمه الخرطوم تحديدا قرب جسر الماكنيمر
احد ثلاثه جسور واصله بين الخرطوم
والخرطوم بحري هكذا تبدو العاصمه مسرح
العمليات ومحاولات السيطره بين الطرفين
خصوصا محيط القصر الجمهوري مع الضغط
المتواصل على المنطقه من المحاور الشماليه
للعاصمه يقول الجيش السوداني نقوات الدعم
السريع ما زالت تقصف مناطق وسط الخرطوم
بشكل عشوائي رغم تاكيد الجيش ان وضع
العاصمه مستقر جدا باستثناء ولايه غرب
دارفور هناك على الحدود السودانيه
التشاديه حيث مدينه الجنينه عاصمه ولايه
غرب دارفور التي كانت على موعد مع هجمات
للدعم السريع على مقر حكومه الولايه
[موسيقى]